merci la parole est à monsieur edouard
courtial
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au garde des sceaux monsieur
ministre il est toujours facile d'être
généreux avec l'argent des autres
et c'est bien cette ligne de conduite
que vous avez adopté vis-à-vis des
départements que vous obliger à assurer
à leurs frais l'accueil des mineurs
étrangers isolés ou non-accompagnés
comme vous les appelez maintenant ce qui
change rien au problème d accord de
répartition entre votre ministère et les
départements avaient été trouvés en 2013
l'oise devait accueillir cinquante six
mineurs étrangers isolés
or ils sont à ce jour près de 308 le
calcul est simple c'est donc 250 de plus
les capacités d'accueil sont saturées
les places sont occupées à 200%
monsieur le ministre dans ces conditions
nous ne pouvons plus assurer leur
sécurité ni celle des jeunes oisiens
accueillis dans nos structures
c'est pourquoi en mon âme et conscience
j'ai dû décider de refuser tout nouvel
accueil de mineurs étrangers isolés ne
faisant pas l'objet d'une ordonnance de
placement
malgré cela les arrivées se multiplient
et le problème s'aggrave de jour en jour
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence à ce
que vous vous saisissiez enfin du
problème
tout d'abord donné instruction à vos
services notamment au procureur de ne
pas surcharger les départements ensuite
donné instruction à vos services
centraux de revoir ce système de
répartition qui ne fonctionne pas enfin
l'oise comme de nombreux départements
n'ayant pas les moyens de faire face à
ce décalage entre la répartition prévue
et la réalité une prise en charge
financière par l'état est incontournable
et je manquerai pas d'ailleurs de vous
envoyer la facture correspondant 12
millions d'euros en 2015 soit autant que
la baisse de la dgf subie par le
département de l'oise la même année
monsieur le ministre
notre devoir est d'éviter l'explosion
nos territoires la ruine de nos
départements
c'est pourquoi je refuse d'assumer les
conséquences humaines et financières des
décisions que vous prenez seul
merci la parole et à monsieur jacques
urvoas garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
député
ce n'est pas moi qui le décide c'est
tout simplement l'application de la loi
qui a été rappelé par ailleurs par le
conseil d'état c'est de la
responsabilité des collectivités
départementales au titre de la
protection de l'enfance vous savez comme
moi et si vous ne le savez pas demandez
le à dominique bussereau avec lequel je
travaille très bien
au nom de l'association des départements
de france sur cette question nous avions
une cellule de répartition auprès de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse de
façon à répertoire de répartir les
mineurs non accompagnés en fonction des
capacités des départements est aussi
décision des procureurs cette circulaire
du compte de la pjj a été annulée par le
conseil d'état
ce qui fait que pendant des mois nous
n'avons pas pu travailler
la circulaire a trouvé une solution plus
tôt l'annulation par le conseil d'état a
trouvé une solution
le 14 mars dernier par l'adoption par
l'assemblée nationale et par le sénat
d'une proposition de loi de madame les
sénatrices meunier et midi qui ont
permis de redonner une base légale
la cellule vous le savez monsieur le
député puisque vous avez répondu à mes
services
la cellule travail depuis le 12 avril
parce qu'avec dominique bussereau avec
l'association des départements de france
nous avons décidé de trouver une
nouvelle clé de répartition il y à un
décret vous le savez monsieur le député
vous avez répondu mais vous avez répondu
vous avez répandu mais je vous
répondrais fait du droit nous avons et
je ne veux vraiment pas faire de
polémique là-dessus parce que c'est là à
charge exponentielle que ça représente
pour les départements absolument puisque
à la demande donc de dominique bussereau
et de moi même la totalité il manque
deux départements le morbihan et le
calvados qui ne nous ont pas répondu
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons neuf mille neuf cent soixante dix
mineurs non accompagnés vous avez
répondu d'ailleurs dans votre
département
non pas 308 mais 206 mais je vous dis
nous allons avoir une nous allons avoir
un décret qui sera pris le 10 mai mai